all right a former assistant to Harvey
Weinstein is breaking her silence and
alleging the disgraced Hollywood mogul
tried to rape one of his employees
Zelda Perkins worked at Miramax in the
1990s in her first television interview
she told our partners at the BBC she
felt pressured to quit after confronting
Weinstein over the accusations
gingka Duncan shows us what else Perkins
says she did to try and hold Weinstein
accountable Jericka good morning good
morning Zelda Perkins says she wanted to
go public years ago but was bound by a
non-disclosure agreement and she wasn't
even allowed to keep a copy of it
Perkins now believes had she broken the
agreement sooner other women could have
been spared she was extremely distressed
Zelda Perkins told the BBC's Emily
Maitlis she tried to comfort Harvey
Weinstein's alleged attempted rape
victim clearly in shock didn't want
anybody to know was absolutely terrified
of the consequences what would happen
Perkins alleges Weinstein attacked her
coworker during the 1998 Venice Film
Festival Perkins says she later pulled
him out of a meeting to confront him for
me to have broken into a meeting like
that was very unusual and he did not
question me he got up and came with me
straight away cos he knew why I was why
I was as angry I'm serious as I was so
you accused him of attempted rape yeah
yeah and he denied it
yes and they said nothing at all had
happened and he swore on the life of his
wife and his children which was his his
best get out of jail card that he used
quite a note when she complained to her
female supervisor at Weinstein's movie
company Miramax Perkins says she was
advised to hire a lawyer I naively
believed that if we went to Disney they
would be horrified and would fire Harvey
or you know or help us with the
proceedings the Walt Disney Company
which owned Miramax at the time did not
respond to our request for comment
Perkins later resigned and says she
received a settlement of more than
$200,000 she also signed a nondisclosure
agreement in October of 1998 which
Perkins says she now regrets he put in
this amount of energy into humiliating
men and an enormous amount of energy
into getting women to submit Weinstein's
lawyer released this statement in
response to perkins interview with the
BBC that says quote mr. Weinstein
categorically denies engaging in any
non-consensual conduct or alleged
threatening behavior and will seek the
protection of the UK or Irish courts if
you proceed with the broadcast of these
allegations
Jericka thanks very much